if you're anything like us you had a
neatly organized laundry list of film
circuits last year but with all that
focus on big-ticket films like Star Wars
the last Jedi Wonder Woman and guardians
of the galaxy vol 2 a ton of amazing
pigs have slipped under the radar we're
here to show you the best of the bunch
for the big sick based on the true story
of how Pakistan born aspiring comedian
Kumail Nanjiani met his wife Emily v
Gordon the big sick is a prime example
of a midsummer sleeper hit she's way
look like your new white glove okay wee
hey Tara the big sick rejects soppy
sentimentality in favor of organic
dialogue irresistible sincerity and a
sharp sense of humor even when emily is
struck down with a mysterious illness
that nun Jionni navigates with her
parents Mangione and Zoe Kazan offer up
two of the year's best performances
hilarious and refreshingly honest with
40 jokes and an undeniable emotional
intelligence the big sick is a little
film with a great big heart a ghost
story you may have missed this unique
drama but you're surely recognized
Academy Award winner Casey Affleck and
Academy Award nominated Rooney Mara as a
husband and wife that have been
separated by death Affleck plays a
struggling musician turned white sheeted
ghost straight out of well a ghost story
as he slips away Affleck works too a lot
questions of his past along with the
Enigma of existence directed by David
Laurie the film is bursting with fantasy
creating an experience that lingers on
the pangs of love and the hope hidden in
grief the survivalist
directed by Stephen Fingal turn the
survivalists imagines a post-apocalyptic
wilderness where Irish actor Martin
McCann protects his makeshift farm home
invaders with shotguns and traps when an
ailing woman offers a beautiful teenage
daughter in exchange for shelter he
mistakenly lets his guard down ravaged
by lust he turns his back on his code
and opens up a world of untold danger
the survivalist debuted at Tribeca in
2015 but didn't screen in America until
May of 2017 it's high contrast color
palettes fast-paced and
thought-provoking plots have earned
critical acclaim be prepared to watch
this one from the edge of your seat mind
horn produced by Ridley Scott and
directed by Sean Foley this British
indie senses are make-believe actor
Richard thorn craft who tasted fame as
horn an 80s TV detective three decades
later he's a shadow of his former self
with no acting work to keep him busy
the self-involved egomaniac has to track
down a mind horn obsessed murderer who
will only fess up to the fictional
character goofy gags high-profile cameos
and cheeky one-liners push mine horn
into instant gem territory we're all
gonna die get over it
some of the bang some of the whimper
some with a weird wasting disease paints
it black lauded for its visual beauty
complex narrative and solid performances
actress amber tamblyn's directorial
debut painted black got a low-profile
release during its theatrical run the
film follows the destructive rivalry of
alia Shawkat Josie and Janet mcteer's
Meredith after the death of her
boyfriend Michael
Josie attempts to piece together the
circumstances of his death the process
forces her closer to his mother the
menacing Meredith it's simply the only
way to learn the truth however
nightmarish it may be good time Robert
Pattinson has come a long way from his
glittering vampire days never has s been
more ever done learning good time a
gritty and gorgeous crime drama directed
by sibling duo Josh and Betty softy
Pattinson plays Constantine aka Connie
who robs a bank with his developmentally
disabled brother Nick when Nick gets
courts Connie races against the clock
and through the city's dangerous
underbelly in a desperate attempt to
free his brother from prison with its
contradictory title good timer swept up
acclaim and Industry accolades including
a nomination for the cannes film
festival palme d'or Logan lucky in
Steven Soderbergh high-octane heist
comedy Logan lucky Channing Tatum stars
as an average blue-collar Joe who lost
everything as let go for liability
reasons involve an insurance he recruits
his one-armed brother played by Adam
driver and a number of other zany
characters to rob a major NASCAR
speedway featuring an explosive made of
gummy bears a heartfelt rendition of
take me home country roads and stellar
performances from a list actors it's
hard to believe Logan lucky flew under
anyone's radar but that's all the more
reason to see you as soon as possible
lucky this film about an independent 90
year old atheist showing of complexity
and emotional weight that resonate both
on and off screen in his final film the
late
Harry Dean Stanton stars as lucky a
retired World War two veteran in search
of enlightenment at the end of his life
the warmly lit Arizona landscape and
deeply engrossing narrative make you
wish you hadn't miss Stanton's glorious
swan song but you'll feel lucky to have
seen it once you finally do super dark
times this is a case where our film's
title perfectly describes its events
super dark times is a visceral thriller
about two teenage best friends at
growing up in the suburbs in the 90s
their lives center around comic books by
Chrysler the corner store Friday night
hangouts first romances and the quest
for high school popularity but when a
truly unthinkable incident occurs the
boys lose their innocence and each other
as they navigate the murky waters of the
tragedy and it's aftermath super dark
times rides a fine line between boyhood
and manhood good and evil horror and
valor spilling out onto the silver
screen in waves of slow burning terror
that will grip you by the throat three
billboards outside ebbing Missouri
Academy award-winning director Martin
mcdonoughs three billboards outside
Irving Missouri stars Frances McDormand
as a single mother determined to seek
justice for her daughter who was
violently murdered the local police
departments failure to make headway in
the case pushes mcdorman to rent three
abandoned billboards and paint each of
them with bold messages directed at the
Chief of Police
played by Woody Harrelson as she clashes
with the townspeople an increasingly
turbulent showdowns that are quick to
violence officer Dixon played by Sam
Rockwell enters a pitcher sending
shockwaves through the town with
exceptional performances three
billboards as harrowing humorous and
completely unforgettable Sylvia Sylvio
isn't your average comedy ken Tucker
oddly and Alba Bernie's joint effort
follows Sylvia Bernard a as he copes
with newfound small-town Fame oh yeah
and he's also a gorilla this endearing
indie will surprise you with its
authenticity the eponymous Apes life is
turned around when after appearing on a
television show he's mistaken for a
performer and turned into an overnight
sensation however with reputation comes
repercussions and the gentle primate has
to consider everything he knows about
himself and what kind of influence the
people in his life truly have on him
brawl in cell block 99 you'd never
expect to see actor Vince Vaughn bold
and come
in blood and tattoos but that's exactly
why as Craig Zola gives you with his
thriller brawl in cell block 99 form
plays Bradley Thomas a former boxer and
recovering alcoholic who returns to
dealing drugs after losing his job
things start looking up but then a
violent drug pickup lands Thomas with a
10-year prison sentence gonner his days
spent with his loving wife he now must
face cellblock 99 a place where savagery
reigns supreme
while this thriller saw only a limited
release critics are calling it a perfect
example of a down-and-dirty exploitation
flick and perhaps Vaughn's very best
work to date
Thelma this in Irving Hitchcockian
thriller slowly builds to bursting
directed by Norwegian filmmaker
Joaquim tria Thelma stars oily Harbo as
a young woman who waves goodbye to a
religious family and moves to the
bustling city of Oslo for university as
Selma discovers new things about herself
she also starts suffering from violent
tremors that seemed to become more
aggressive as her feelings towards Anja
a beautiful student to grow stronger as
it turns out Thelma has supernatural
powers which forced her to face the
darkness of her past
don't let the foreign language aspect of
Thelma turn you away the bone-chilling
scares and shocking twists are
universally understood thanks for
watching click the loop icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love tea
[Music]